what is this katma hat shit
fucking hate this movie if you can't
find it on YouTube by the way I just go
to channel if it's there oh but we're
fighting all the all the ones are
getting taken down on YouTube by the way
we are fighting them I mean we are it is
always the piece-of-shit movies - yeah
when you preserve the sanctity of Mamma
Mia of Cat in the Hat
Mike Meyers has deep pockets people
might actually think it's a bad movie
I'm sure we're the only ones to say it
oh but hey what oh fuck this movie um
yeah that's okay can we just make this
be like nothing but a state over and
over office monk fuck fuck fuck this
fucking movie in its motherfucking ass
you know oh it's the first film from Bo
Welch this is I think his first
directing effort what a horrible film
the start on because what a phenomenal
talent yet bulge is a production
designer who's done a lot of the glut of
the firm's stuff yeah yeah I mean minute
laughs yeah I mean just unbelievable
Talent and directed in production San
fermín and I I have no idea if this was
mostly him or the studio I had to guess
I'd say it's the studio the studio
that's trying so hard to make sure we
never run it yeah and it's one of those
things where because god help us if we
tell the truth about can't man the cuz
fucking branch came out and I still how
could any of you like that movie come on
Kennex oh people like them oh people
lose that moving Wow like no there
that's what the ending of that that's
really kind of a soul-crushing I didn't
I
I mean almost say this is not the worst
of those movies but I mean this I think
is the worst of those movies I'd say
second honestly I think this is just
under can the Hat I mean think if you
have the Lorax which hey lauryn yeah
Lorax i think is the best of them no no
horny here's a new his problem oh I
haven't seen horn
my face I would agree with you and I
would say Horton then Lorax yeah then
branch they can the Hat so this is this
is rock-bottom I mean it is but like the
only thing I can figure is that it's
kind of like Space Jam where people just
kind of grew up with it and like Jim
Carrey and it is visually you know kind
of interesting I scaredy Shannon I was
young but you know at some point you
grow up no no I think I I mean because I
like Jim Carrey and some things doesn't
mean I have to like them and everything
it doesn't mean I can't look back on
films and I saw when I was like 10 and
be like ya know my favorite is the Robot
Chicken when it's like this it's some
sort of Christmas rhyme and it's like
the Grinch that stole Christmas or
something like that and this kid comes
up and he goes oh no it's the piece of
shit Jim Carrey Grinch that's a real
good are we gonna do her no cuz everyone
when that movie came out he critics it
like but everyone's like it wasn't that
great wasn't that great wasn't Jim
Carrey amazing wasn't that great it's
like oh no and I'm like this is gonna be
everywhere now and it fucking was and
then they we finally climax it with the
worst with Cat in the Hat and people are
like you know maybe this whole thing
we're doing with dr. Seuss you know
ain't no raping his grave isn't the best
and we should actually try to put effort
into this shit and they get anal rapings
not harsh enough skull-fucking
yeah I think that's better and you know
so then when Laurie's came out they they
tried a little harder buddy guess you
know at least it looked like the book uh
but still just missed so much words
missed the point on a lot of things but
in the grand scheme of things I find a
way more mostly harmless like to me it's
mostly harmless just yeah you missed the
boat on that one but you know what it's
it's not getting that yeah no I mean for
me it's the big thing for me that's what
they're doing the dr. Seuss is in the
movies anyway is that there it is what a
few times where I say this feels like an
insult because I people work hard on
these movies they come together they
have to say
mr. Rogers and turning it into some
cheap corporate shield product yeah and
it's just as soon as I was old wrong
since I was so perfect and so wholesome
it's so brilliantly done and well done
and hit a perfect message just
everything about it's just about as
perfect a product yeah that felt uh but
but do we have mrs. alpha oh no we need
Jim Carrey having a fucking guy kiss a
dog spotted having his hand in a woman's
brass and stuff that's doctors soon as
dr. Seuss with any - it's that fucking
dog from The Simpsons that Homer voiced
in dr. Seuss and fuck you for it just
fuck you for it I'm sorry I get really
fucking angry at this I hate cuz I've
gone on and on about this in the reviews
about how they just see it
oh let's just kid stuff we get this cuz
we're adults and no you don't and you
don't see what was so brilliant about
this writing and about these stories and
wider thailand's and yours are going to
die and they're going to be shit and
more people are waking up and realizing
that they are shit and they should be
dead and that this great word is gonna
stand it's gonna live forever because he
fucking tried if you respected kids and
he respected adults all the hate that's
gonna be in the comments like no no no
I'll bring it bring it up yeah I don't
you know I will say I don't think I hate
the Grinch as much as you do it's be
shit but I you know I don't think it
inspires that much hate the can the Hat
does though this movie was so
inseparable to get through first off
Mike Myers in probably one of the most
greatest most spectacular failed
performances like ever put on the screen
like if people think Johnny Depp is bad
in Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
like it that this whole people like him
in that - hi not every fucking weird
some people thought he is Michael
Jackson Willy Wonka was a bizarre I I
don't um
this yeah what one of the great failed
performances of all time but not even
entertaining to watch fail because you
want a great fail performance Dennis
Hopper is King Koopa that's a Super
Mario nominal failed one of the greatest
failed performances a Christopher
Lambert is Raiden he's so great to watch
beautifully found bad uh you know we
we've had so many great Arnold
Schwarzenegger mr. freeze just one of
the great failed performance how do we
Jones's to face
yeah you just you launder well fail yeah
just so entertaining to wellness ass so
awful but so fun to watch it's just fun
how much they failed you just like you
know what that's hilarious
this I what scene was it where I snapped
okay no there is a seat it's the same
with the NC snaps to wear uh like Micah
skated in the nuts and they have on a
swing in a checkered dress playing this
song and that just cuts back what you do
reenact and we're watching does that
seem okay so keep in mind throughout
this entire movie I am sitting there
like this I am like God make it stop and
that scene happens and he gets kicked in
the balls and I'm like I would have been
yeah way over here like we're on the cab
you know just watch out I knew this even
boy yeah I was like way over here and
that scene happen and this literally
happened
watch our guys and then we just sort of
sat there in silence I'm not making this
up that really I I literally fucking
snapped as how much I hate this movie
it's it was it was so hard to find you
as I had your face you were just like
well that's the first I think you were
just like why don't we pause yeah like
we just needed a break it was just so
relentless and how terrible it was and
you know what's so funny is that the
great
so bad um and I it's hard to say which
one is the bigger insult because I can
hat is worse it's a worse movie uh the
Grinch I I think is a much stronger
story uh if there's so much more to
break down which was an s of the the
thing that offends me most about Cat in
the Hat as bad as the Grinch gets and
sniffing the dog's butt and all that
like in Jim Carrey prancing man as bad
as it is and even though obviously was
advertised there were toys and stuff and
movie tie-ins I still feel in in the
world of the movie itself it wasn't as
much of a corporate shill yeah like it
was bad but it was its own thing it's
like we're still gonna have a moral even
though it's completely derailed by all
the advertising around this film can in
the head though I think was the
universal ad they threw in there that
insulted me the most I'm like okay you
know you could argue that it's just a
failed idea a failed interpretation of
dr. Seuss but one thing I never never
would have associated with dr. Seuss is
just like an ad for universal like theme
parks like by the way there's a dog it's
just land at Universal teen by Eddy it
looks gorgeous finally I'm not sure I
just go there then watch this move it
could just put that in your movie I'm
like okay so that's why this movie
exists I mean that was it that is the
reason this movie existed right there
like it's just a cheap ad well and
everything about it feels like well the
Grinch was a hit so try and do kind of
what they do with the Grinch just make
it I hid different cuz my fires is
clearly doing like what Jim Carrey was
trying to sort of a funny voice that's a
little different from what we've seen
like in the cartoon and other
interpretations uh with some adult
jogger they're said to be adult apply
those childish things and uh I don
cultured I know I don't hate Mike Meyer
Easy's don't know no I don't you sell a
lot of things I found very funny in the
past but to think that you could do Jim
Carrey
not gonna happen Larry you can only do
Jim Carrey and even then Jim Carrey's
annoying when he's doing Jim Carrey's
other thing that you could imitate Jim
Carrey no like it just so bombs well I
think there's something
I'm not saying it all that Mike Myers
probably didn't try his hardest to work
in this suit and stuff like that but
Jill I said you carry just like when
when you hear him on interviews and like
I don't like the performance in grapes
but when you hear about interviews how
he worked with his makeup and this suit
and he had to do like meditation had to
do this Zen type mental you know
breaking down where he said I think he
said you could hit me with a baseball
bat and I'd be like hi how are you yes I
am you you appreciate and you see it in
the performance at least cuz he just
owns that suit he owns that makeup and I
never once thought to myself oh well
yeah that looks uncomfortable that looks
tricky to do cuz he just sold and it
must have been a nightmare must have
been probably the toughest things of my
diet is doesn't have the face I mean Jim
Carrey has the the ability to contort
his face in such a way that everybody
and his body but even in the face like
the abilities that contort his face in
such a way that you can bring it out
through the suit and Mike Meyers does
not he just does not have that talent or
the the muscles necessary in your face
to do it or really even his body and
again I'm not if I was put him in a suit
like that it's like it's not just a Mike
Myers fail like it's a fail on everybody
involved nobody looked at that suit for
10 seconds and thought what the fuck are
we doing like what because I could look
at the Jim Carrey Grinch as much as I
don't like that movie either I'm like
the most amazing I'm like he's the
Grinch yeah I get it I look at Mike
Meyers as the kanima hand I'm like what
the fuck is that I wanna keep this thing
away from me yeah I don't I hate I don't
want this thing in it I will let Johnny
Depp as Michael Jackson Willy Wonka next
to my children and I will this thing and
the the suit constantly looks like it's
it is what is it's a restrictive painful
thing to be in and even we smile a good
Google are doing whatever voice email
say this so it's not as hideousness
thing 1 and thing 2 oh yeah that was
that freaking haunted miner I did not I
did not get one wink of sleep that night
not even for a minute I just every time
I close my eyes I would see thing 1 and
thing 2 and I would just go ahh you know
as much as we don't like the Grinch
we'll sort of acknowledge like there's
some things in there that like either
see
they were trying to do it you know
calves in a good way or one or two
things kind of worked but not really
that many there isn't it's like Tamm
everything yeah everything that didn't
work in the Grinch is in katma had the
crush and boys faces as much as the
Grinch bombs on a number of things at
least it's an attempt to make a movie
I'll never take that away from anyone
who wants to argue that that I'm like
okay they threw some effort into this
they're trying to tell a story and a
narrative it doesn't always work but
it's there there's just not I mean the
can the head it's not even one of my
favorite Seuss story it's not what it's
well at the bottom I realize he's
basically the sous mascot that's not
that's not caring that much about Mickey
Mouse it's like we did he's the mascot
is the least interesting most of the
Disney character it makes a fucking
live-action Mickey Mouse movie with like
a guy in a Mickey Mouse Oh bad idea in
all over it oh and another good idea bad
idea and yeah I think it's one of those
things where they obviously try to
recreate what they thought worked in the
Grinch and I'm so happy that I mean I
have yet to meet a person who liked this
movie I'm sure there's somebody out
there but I have yet to meet them and
now they do people not like it they say
with a few pounds was awful not like
they hate it with a passion almost as
much as we it's one of the few films
where if somebody is out there who did
like it I don't want to beat them is
gonna end well
but this is one of the few uh normally
almost always I miss a guy you know you
see something good anything you know
people who like the Grinch I'm like
alright I joke korean soul-crushing my
mind I'm sure I could find a way to get
along with somebody like Grichuk in the
head I'm not so sure no I'm not so sure
I could do it not not and nut and
preserve my soul a limit is left you
know it gave me hope I'm asleep aged
maybe I don't know it just gave me hope
that people hated this film as much as
they did in people and and what I love
is people trying to rationalize why you
know
well the Grinch had this in the cabinet
like they couldn't tell why they liked
one and why they didn't like the other
and I mean in some respect I couldn't
quite tell either but it
have we said where it's like the grinch
at least was attempting to make a movie
even to Ron Howard's credit he says
something that I desire Lee kind of
respected cuz he's a huge Chuck Jones
fan and he loves the Grinch and what he
said about the movie is that he said you
know the Chuck Jones one is so classic
and so good and so perfect that we
didn't even attempt to try and retell it
which in some respect is like then why
are you directing this at all I mean
when but at least but at the very least
there's kind of an understanding where
with this one there's just you could
totally see like you said it was just
corporate make money Grinch was a hit
trying one with my design one of the
most shameless cynical corporate pieces
of shit probably ever put to screen like
it just I I don't even know how you make
something this cynical where it's just
like yeah let's make a quick buck like
off of dr. Seuss it just I have you
sleeping nice having done that I did
it's it's like you should be put on
trial she like war crimes go to The
Hague and what and here's what here's
why I found out there some people are
some artists who work well with the
blank sheet of paper and I'm not sure
and I'm not talking about beau Welles
here I'm talking about the studio
corporate Minds behind this there's some
artists that work well with just a blank
sheet of paper and say draw whatever you
want there's other artists who need some
direction draw a pony it can look
however you want just draw a pony or
something and with this it with cat
ahead I can't feel them because Grinch
had a very specific story and even if
you don't tell it well it's there and
with cat the Hat there's kind of it's
the most minimal of story so on the one
hand there's very little to go with and
there's very little direction to start
off and it's like well what do you do
with the can ahead it's just that
there's so little but on the other hand
you can look at as that blank sheet of
paper
do whatever you want the sky's the limit
and I feel like they sort of went the
route of yellow will give you some
derail give you like sir incorporate
this and get that and get the celebrity
and get this
and put this person in there and stuff
and I think you clearly need someone who
would look at that sheet of paper and
just do whatever I want
oh my god I am so happy thank you God to
do this we can't in the Hat cuz I know
can the head you know they say there's
like no story or anything but it's like
you could make a good movie on that just
how the possibilities of what the can
the head could do with the worlds he
could create and the characters and
think one thing - what you could do with
them you please been someone trying to
figure out if you could this time I
think if you should know if you really
want to try and do a good can the Hat
movie I think it's possibly be very
difficult but it is possible you would
have to have someone that like just has
this endless amount of imagination like
you know you mean like a Miyazaki or
something like that cuz we learn i
honestly more male are paid to time the
city we just found out about we just got
a mad bags which like you know those
less scary the cab yeah and it's not
like you know it's not a particularly
wordy story so it like he's proven he
can do stuff like that where you know
you take a little and you make a lot out
of it I guess oh yeah no it's one of
those things where it's like you this
this could happen OTT against the idea
of it happening but you don't have to
take a lot of care and a lot of thought
and somebody who would really want to do
it and it's clear and mostly people
working that I mean I'm sure Pablo's was
happy to be working on a film finally
you know do have a film uh I thought
it's just not fair to both well yeah I
mean further he's directing he's tried
to like episodes of the tick and stuff
like that so he has I don't know and I
think pushing up daisies II did yeah
like he's done some of those and stuff
so I did it he's fine and he definitely
likes some really quirky odd words a big
shock from a guy like that well also
does the production as I was about the
only thing that was halfway decent about
them but even that I mean was like cut X
such a yeah it's such a nightmare to who
is it's kind of like this color
everything looks like prison bars to me
like the walls and the color and
everything it only shows you why
something they work better in animation
than they do live action yeah um you
know even watching uh for when I was
doing the review I went and I watched
the old cat
at Khartoum the the Friz Freleng one uh
because I forgot actually several one of
her directors did did dr. Seuss and
frisk really I think actually did more
than Chuck Jones I think don't quote me
on that but but he did the can the head
and he got the I swear the smokers brain
chilly guy I think he was the guy doing
the Kevin what I liked about it they had
to add more than what was in the book I
mean that they all do uh they gave him
kind of this edge to him there really
was kind of assist assist I'm the fish
would talk you could just tell he
clearly wasn't listening and he's like
you know we're good shit just though he
was kind of the troublemaker and I think
that's why people relate to the Baltic
you know what this is like it's the
first book and say you know what dr.
Seuss is saying a little bit of trouble
is okay and how often do you see a kid
book saying that yes not on in this this
one is just like though have our kid a
fucking Joker's on the movies gonna kill
him he's so fucking psychotic that you
know what it plays like it's almost like
one two hour-long Robot Chicken joke
like it's a spoof of kid maad where it's
like now the can the heads really
psychotic that's the joke yeah like
breakdown Tory says I'm not good at
rhyming it's like oh okay I let a my
anger I haven't a tear left to shit um
but ya know this this one maybe in my
top five yeah somewhere like below
maybe Mamma Mia and Garbage Pail Kids ya
know that this like this is this is in
my tablet most of yes sufferable movie
experiences yeah I mean out of all of
them at every so far every dr. Seuss
movie has said son some element of
insult to what dr. Seuss was doing and
in a new creative way but some are
obviously trying harder than whore
teachers of who is not adamant shred you
have dignity in it to say you know what
we are gonna try to say something it
means something even if it ain't much
we're gonna try this is the one that is
zero yes decision by far the biggest
insult horde here's the who is probably
the closest it doesn't work
good movie but I don't think it's bad
enough to do a review because people
didn't ask me I'm like it's it's not bad
enough to get like a lot of funny
material on it but it's the closest to
following the spirit acts had a lot of
problems but it was pretty and I'm like
all right beneath all of your mistakes
is still a moral there I guess and then
even you know what it is Lorax I could
almost see how this movie would work I
guess almost see how they would pull it
off and then they fuck it all really
inches a failed Ron Howard experiment
and again I'm like well I mean the moral
is in there somewhere like but but this
this there's just nothing it is the
biggest we are not gonna try to do a
fucking thing that dr. Seuss it's a shit
it's literally the movie was a shakedown
they got a bunch of that you basically
all the stood it was a studio shakedown
where they let a bunch of kids into the
theater pulled out guns grabbed the kids
shook all the money other pockets tossed
mom said go fuck yourself that's what
this one is
that's all this movement is what a
wonderful visual for that that's all it
is and like this is somebody who had to
sit through like Super Mario Brothers as
a kid and like I've said through a lot
of but this one is the biggest insult I
think I've ever had to sit through yeah
um just not only are we not going to
follow the source material but we are
gonna rub our asses in how much we're
not gonna follow it yeah at least at
least the Super Mario Brothers movie
didn't have you know like an
advertisement for Nintendo Power
surprisingly surprisingly it didn't I'm
like well at least they had the dignity
what you think that was some wizard I
think the wizard was less of a corporate
shill movie and then boy he is a giant
average but for Super Mario Brothers 3
at least it tried to be a movie yeah at
some point like I you know what though
cuz it all like went in - when I saw the
Wizard all I went in to see was a
preview of Super Mario Brothers 3 and
that's what I got so really by the logo
some healthy by below standards I set
for myself as like a 10 or 11 year
at the time I got what I needed I cannot
imagine being 10 years old and walking
in to see Cat in the Hat and enjoying it
I imagine throwing up it's not a few
movies where when I leave I feel dirty
I feel unclean I feel despicable I just
feel ugly and the world looks lovely
after see hair bears were created as
greeting-card like it's basically a
giant commercial for greeting cards and
that movie had more dignity and I
enjoyed that movie as a kid I can I try
to think of all the dumb things I
enjoyed as a kid the stupidest things
I'm like what I've liked this movie and
I ahead no I don't think I would have I
think I would have either been bored I
think I would very terrified yeah it's I
don't think I ever would have watched it
again I would more likely seeing the
Grinch and enjoyed that as a small child
yeah but Cat in the Hat no no it's yeah
like I said even as a little kid I could
probably see myself liking the Grinch um
yeah the Jim Carrey cringe I could see
myself liking I could even see an age
where I would probably like that more
than the animated one like whatever 12
13 I want my boob jokes I want my Jim
Carrey I want my pop cultural records I
could see that uh and yeah and I cannot
see anyone uh being satisfied with can't
mahan if anything I would feel like
still being given something you have had
a lot taken away from you uh and take it
away from you yet so much filler thrown
in yeah keep the movie like a two-hour
running time yeah so it's uh see I think
it's not like the long one of the
longest movies ever had to sit through I
don't like thinking about it just
thinking about it brings me back to that
moment when I strangle to you and I'm
just like oh god this fucking movie yeah
yeah much makes me feel miss it's like
you know what it's like reliving a
traumatic experience I'm having like
like post-traumatic stress to sort of
flashback ya know it's one of those when
I was talking about like which you know
the Grinch or Kappa house or the bigger
you know like which one makes me a
little angry it's like the Grinch I'll
talk about more because I think it comes
from a story I love so much and was done
so well okay can the head is a is really
a zombie brilliant book but it's not one
of my personal favorites and even the
cartoon he's done very well but it's you
know I don't hold it to this I
turkey so when I when I see it it's like
it's clearly the worst film I get a
little bit more angry about Grinch
because like I said because I do hold
that to such a high standard but can the
Hat by far is not only the worst film
but it is like just the most painful
together and most painful to sit through
yeah that is kind of rare that I think
of a movie I like what I really think
about like yeah just just a bad feeling
just a bad ugly feeling so it's actually
filled with negative energy yeah so
that's about it I think we're almost on
film here too so uh yeah guy well what
else can we say about just um